let's check out this story here
California governor Gavin Newsom admits
the Democrats have been destroyed on
messaging and crushed in the narrative
as they race a republican Red Wave in
the midterms and here's the RCP
projection there it is the updated map
shows Republicans taking 54 seats
Democrats 46 New Hampshire is going
Republican they're saying Arizona Nevada
Georgia New Hampshire
all going Republican
now I got a question if zeldin in some
polls is leading in New York could New
York possibly go Republican the Senate
as well that'd be huge you you could
could you imagine what would happen if
the Republicans actually took over 60
Senate seats
that'd be crazy that's a lot of pod
people in New York City I'm gonna start
calling people that live in apartments
and in deep cities pod people it's kind
of it's kind of a term of endearment
guys I know you're listening right now
no it's not
a pod for many years so it's not it's
not an insult they're looking around the
apartment from wall to wall like uh five
feet to five feet is going yeah I guess
cement so as as everyone in here has
always been the staunchest of
Republicans uh how are you gonna
celebrate how are you guys how are you
going to celebrate when your favorite
political party wins Supreme control
over the government in a week you're
just trying to trigger me right now
trigger you no one I I don't like you're
not even American Serge are you
Republican no then no one in this room
has has been a traditional Republican no
and here we are being like Oh it's
better they win I guess yeah yeah I mean
we can acknowledge the Republican party
is mostly trash but we don't want the
Democrats to win when it comes to this I
don't even know who the Democrats are
that are running so to be honest I vote
for people I don't vote for political
parties and if the people are better but
they have a better shirt I will not vote
for John I would not Advocate voting for
John Federman because like he just
suffered a stroke he's not in a healthy
mind state right now I'm not a huge fan
of Dr Oz politically but he seemed
cogent he's more cogent than fitment at
least you know yeah yeah if Republicans
today or just for Democrats
a little time there before they fully
Implement all the agenda when the uh who
does the RCP Real Clear Politics how do
they get their numbers it's a it's a a
an aggregation of polls so you've got a
bunch of different polls that's whether
basically yeah we also got to understand
the polls are routinely wrong they're
telling you that Hillary Clinton had a
99 to 90 chance of winning the election
but they're they're wrong by like seven
points against the Dem against the
Republicans meaning if they're using the
polls to show a projection of 54
Republican seats and they're off again
by 7 to 13 points that was like the
swing I mean it could be way more I
don't yeah look if the let's say this so
when we look at uh New York Senate
Schumer versus pinyin Schumer is up 18
11 17 14 and 12. if the polls are off by
13 points and that's that's massive I
really doubt it I really doubt it then
it could be a tie but I I don't think so
I do think however if people in New York
go out and vote they absolutely could
get a republican in the Senate New York
if every single person went out and vote
the polls are meaningless because
Democrats aren't enthusiastic right now
they're upset about Democratic
Leadership the gas prices are too dang
high and so right now the Republicans
who are enthusiastic have have an
opportunity these polls show Schumer way
up sure but how many of those people
want to vote for him say who say they're
going to vote for him actually care to
go out and vote the Democrats aren't
offering you anything so they might not
even show up
I I kind of worry about blue Texas at
the end of the day I mean ever since for
California started running away events
saying oh wait California sucks where
it's votes exactly the same in our new
state I think we could see some
surprises but Texas has been turning
redder yeah that's good that's good news
that's because a lot of conservatives
have been no no no no the Latino vote in
South in this in in the Rio Grande
Valley flipped from Democrat to
Republican yes so I mean people are fed
up with the Border crisis yeah not only
people that are from like is that where
Elon Musk also voted you voted also for
a republican yeah he said anybody
Republican yeah Elon musk's good look at
this New Mexico is being projected as
going Democrat right for the for the
governorship but if the polls really are
busted swinging up to seven points then
it's it's actually leading Republican
but I don't know I'm not a pollster I
don't know to what degree the polls will
or won't be busted this time around New
Mexico doesn't have any uh Senators up
Colorado the Bennett in Colorado against
O'Day is up uh two points in the latest
Paul from trafalgars eight from Emerson
six from Marist and nine from dfp
overall spread is 6.2 if the polls are
off by seven points Republican could win
there everyone needs to go out and vote
what does it show in Arizona with uh
Carey Lake uh with Carrie Lake oh I
think it's it's hands down I think the
projection it's showing it's contested
no it's up like across the board oh wow
yeah there's like one there's one one
poll showing a tie and one with Hobs up
one but let's look at um
Senate in the Senate Arizona is leaning
see this is interesting all the polls
show Mark Kelly leading in Arizona yet
they're projecting Masters will win
why is that yeah well it'll be
interesting to see what happens man
be right one way because because they're
project because is it is it because
they're like hey look we think the polls
are going to be wrong New Hampshire I
think even shows for the most part
Hassan is up but Bolduc is up one in the
Saint Anselm poll didn't Tulsi
campaigned for uh Baltic yeah she just
endorsed them I'm pretty sure right yeah
oh no no she just endorsed Masters
Tulsi gab amazing that she left Congress
and is more influential now maybe that's
why she did it might have been yeah she
couldn't have done anything in the part
in the party who knows she could have
left the Democratic party a while before
it is very true yeah Bernie too yeah
Duckworth man Illinois what is wrong
with these places I mean it's going to
be interesting to see what happens in
Arizona and Pennsylvania I mean that's
pretty much where I'm going to be
keeping a close eye on on Election Day
because that's going to decide the
future of this country oh yeah what's
the Pennsylvania polls look like right
now Doug mastron I think it's favoring
fetterman yeah he's up point four how I
don't even know decision desk said Oz's
chance of winning is 54 to like
fetterman's 45 after that debate I I you
maybe you should have to watch the
debate to vote I don't know but how do
you know how do you make sure that's why
I think service guarantees citizenship
right oh you don't even need ID to vote
trust me they're not going to uh any
barriers to entry this this right here I
feel like with fetterman and Oz it's
like a test aliens are putting us
through and they're like they're in the
spaceship and it's like are they voting
for fetamine they are ah like they're
testing us to see if we're worthy of
joining the Galactic Federation but
we're voting for a guy who's who's
actually got brain damage and can't
speak or understand words that just goes
to show you that these people are not
serious people the voters are not
serious people they don't care and if
anything if there was a conspiracy I'd
argue it was an attempt to make learned
people wish for despotism because you
realize how many stupid people there are
that will vote themselves to jump off a
cliff that's why we built the federal
government to begin with OR at least why
we built the Senate why we aren't a
democracy yeah Republic yeah we have
better men in quotes for now in the
Senate to make sure that the mob doesn't
vote in more honesty I don't know more
honesty making up words right it's okay
to do that it's totally fine all right
so totally okay we're gonna have a big
show on Election Day we're gonna be
we're gonna have pizzas and wings and
we're just gonna sit here I'm gonna eat
like a bowl of wings beef liver I'm
gonna bring the beef liver yeah change
it up
I I gotta I gotta say look if you think
the Republicans won already then they're
gonna lose for real yeah you're not
gonna go out and vote and that's what
that's what they're hoping for the
reason we may be seeing these stories
like Republicans are going to win is
that Republicans like okay I don't gotta
go out no no no now is the time you got
to go out because I'll tell you this if
they're saying you're gonna win already
then make it a super majority make it
like a crushing defeat like people talk
about when you're when you're defending
yourself how you got to make sure you
stop the fight you know you have to make
sure you use adequate Force to prevent
someone from being able to fight when
we're talking about politics you want to
win a decisive political Victory to the
point where the Democrats feel so
demoralized they drop these garbage
ideas they have a Reckoning where they
say Hey you know those things we're
promoting that really hurt us in a way
we've not seen in decades let's not
advocate for those things anymore that's
what we need to see
send a message yeah and also don't
celebrate when your candidate wins you
got to hold their feet to the fire and
make sure that they represent you
properly this it's just a tendency in
American politics for the once they get
into office to just fall into the
oligarchy pocket and it is up to you to
run this country we are running this
country together the people on Election
Day are we gonna are we going to start
early or is it just eight to ten because
it's not eight to ten we're probably
gonna go late there's not gonna be a
members only we're gonna just just chill
here and have pizza because like you
might we have people rotating in and out
we might be waiting a long time to see
what happens in Pennsylvania yeah it may
go on a few days yeah we may be trapped
here live for a few weeks let's do a
Telethon Telethon yeah no I think we
might go we can raise money for beat
blarp all right election night just let
the live stream roll we'll hang out
maybe like as we're chilling for results
play some music maybe we'll work with
the commander next play some Magic
together while we're waiting get some
coffee I like it I like those days where
people just roll in and out kind of like
take seats you get up and leave come
back yeah we're gonna have a bunch of
people here actually and we're gonna
have people chilling in the seats and
they're gonna come in and swap out and
it'll be fun it'll be an extended show
but uh you know we'll see we'll see I
don't know if we can make surge press
the buttons for that long well luckily
I've got some other people that are
learning how to do this too there we go
it's actually a great opportunity so
we'll be like the Buns may be pressed
incorrectly but we don't maybe I'll push
the buttons for a few minutes you don't
want to do it for days and days and days
what kind of what kind of attitude is
this old algorithm we got to wait until
the votes to in Pennsylvania get in
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all all
there